look so we're trying to do a meet up
because I have to be at Mall of America
so I figured I'd be like eh I can meet
you there real quick I didn't want to
disrupt it in any way but it seems like
security is not excited about or
something not all other details yet
you've got to UM move it to the IAP what
do you think Oh flip don't flip tonight
yeah
first first I just want to thank you
guys for all coming out it's very
flattering I'm sure I'm sure you have
plenty other things to do
so all right oh I'm sorry wait let me
get this photo real quick yeah of course
some young some young ass kids you know
[Laughter]
what spot after your dad and I'm like oh
dad Gary I'm like it was close right I
was close the next one app dear baby I
swear she hadn't is gonna be 3 thank you
alright go ahead my man where'd you go
yes ok ok ok and I don't say it's an
Achilles heel that's just you were in
one specific job where that was a need
like for example at Vayner we are where
we're putting more scrutiny on people
that are double bubbling because we want
people deep as they can I think UX
really [ __ ] matters like like it just
really matters it will always be like
the number one the number one thing I
think about now is the UX of the voice
apps because it hasn't been established
like we don't know how to communicate
with Alexa and Google home like
somebody's gonna create the audio UX of
the next world the same way there was UX
designers for the web in the same way
that I used to do
design my dad's liquor store like this I
hop needs to be you xed right it can be
maximized there could be more space
there could be more dollars they could
make more revenue if it was perfect
so you EXO user experiences everything I
think you should never dictate your
long-term life's vision predicated on
the current place you're working at that
I can promise you yeah cool guy man
nothing dude yep the nurse Stan bro and
I got part of your question a lot of
people ask me this people still you know
you hear people talk but people haven't
grasped you know like I only talk about
[ __ ] I know even this book crushing it I
only wrote it not cuz I was in need of
file I never wanted to write the
follow-up to crush it it's only because
the last 18 months I've quadrupled down
on the things that I believed in and the
result like if I did this meet up 22
months ago this room would be a tenth of
the size just would like the fact that
matters is that I wouldn't change
anything because first of all I'm too
happy and so I wouldn't want to [ __ ]
with that right and second of all I just
really believe in my thesis I think well
everybody here under 30 is rushing to do
stuff to close insecurities and
vulnerabilities and it's making them do
things that they're gonna regret
long-term and I just didn't I just you
know what it feels like to be 27 years
old and see your college friends and
then making jokes that you work in your
dad's liquor store like I just was able
to be in my own head and not care about
what anybody else thought and that would
be my biggest piece of advice because I
genuinely believe all of you are in a
rush for that I don't think you care
about a BMW or a Rolex or like spending
a lot of money on a vacation for any
other reason because of the
psychological aspects of how that
positions you to other people I really
believe that and so I just think people
you know
like the young man out if he's here
who's like I'm killing it I want to
start teaching other people he's he's so
young like anybody could do well at Wall
Street the last six years
everybody like if you've lost money on
Wall Street in the last seven years
you should literally retire like and
call it a day and just leave because
it's impossible not to make money right
and so like I think people are caught
I'm saying it over and over I know you a
lot of you pay attention if you're under
32 you are completely misreading the
situation the college debt crisis is
coming this economy will crash and
everybody's behaving like 10 million
raising like if you don't make money
you're vulnerable and so I just I just
think people are miss playing it I'm
very concerned about the lack of
patience people come up they put up the
5 maybe like yeah Gary I love patience
but then I look they aren't deploying
patience way too much debating in your
19 year old head you know eat [ __ ] for
ten [ __ ] years work for somebody
that's smart for free make minimum wage
live with seven homies in a one-bedroom
apartment that's the best way you'll
enjoy the rest of your life that's the
furthest thing from people's minds
everybody's gonna crush it and start a
business and [ __ ] kill it everybody's
so [ __ ] great 99% of these people in
this room have no shot of building a
business that is long-term successful
unless they go super long tail and super
patient yo that's already bad start
[Laughter]
uniike outside on the console yeah
exactly yep yeah I got you I got a lot
first and foremost the number one thing
I tell all my client service people is
you can only control what you can
control most of my client people are so
ideological about their clients 100% of
vaynermedia's clients don't do even 50%
of what I want them to do let me just
say this very clear
100% of vaynermedia's clients aren't
even 50 percent doing behavior I want
them to do to make their business bigger
and I'm Gary Vee
you know you know like so you know I
think you need to be historically
correct so I think the other mistake
that people make is the other way which
is you pander to the client and you're
saying the things that you know they
want to hear you need to be historically
correct you know if you believe in
something you have to die on that sword
because it feels really bad when then
that plays out but you never said
anything because you knew the client
didn't want it and then they're blaming
it for it you're like [ __ ] I always knew
it that's a way worse l then dying on
your own sword and and just recognizing
that you just don't you can't control
[ __ ] like today it's going great and now
that person rotates or leaves the
company and your new person sucks like I
don't dwell on the [ __ ] I can't control
I wanted to eat [ __ ] for a decade and
build this Feiner machine so I could buy
businesses so I will fire the clients
because I have a mission in a fifty-year
macro I eat [ __ ] every [ __ ] day I
dislike being at the mercy of other
people but I know what I'm doing in a 40
year window and so that's why I'm
choosing so since I made that decision I
hate what people like I hate this [ __ ]
I'm like then quit and go if I can do
something else your [ __ ] control
you're an America cool yep okay follow
up to that kind of in the same industry
I work in consulting in a dying industry
credit unions okay old-school mindset I
know it they do not change and I preach
to their pain points they manage and I
build indirect lending which I want to
talk to you about your auto thing okay
the auto 2020 agent 2021 2021 yep I want
to email you that okay
I've worked in that industry okay so
credit unions to work for that industry
yep they won't dive in okay and they're
failing that's their bread and butter
but they won't do it and we watch within
the last five years they've gone from
over 40,000 credit unions in the nation
to under 8,000 yeah I'm super aware he's
shrinking yep so I talked to their pain
points I show them the numbers and they
just shut the door and say no we've got
it on our own how do you get past that
ego I'm trying to don't you don't I
never try to sell to people who are
unsellable I just don't try to convince
anybody if I have a meeting like at a
diner with some pancakes I meet the guy
I tell him my piece he says no I'm like
cool Mazel Tov see yeah just like just
like the film you're this that dude made
like I don't care what Goran does I
don't care what any of you do
like it would be much better if you did
it and it worked and you email me in
four years and I'd feel really nice and
if your life is better it's good but at
the end of the day I can't control you
like I can't I can't control you like I
love feed this new kick where like as
you guys know I'm like stop watching me
right so people think it's cool to email
me and say I've stopped watching you
have unsubscribed but then there let me
let me let me get to the punchline but
then I watched it cuz I'm just curious
I'm like I was pumped about that at
first until I caught something in a
stream once which put me down a rabbit
hole now I look at their behavior so
literally literally the self how I think
people are miss playing it they they
they're watching my stuff I'm proud
about my stuff I think it works they see
a piece of content where I get on this
tangent that I'm desperate for you guys
to do I'm so desperate for you actually
to execute that I get to the extreme
where once in every four months oh look
their camera be like stop [ __ ]
watching me just do so I've watched all
the people that are saying that so they
stop watching me and then they go watch
worse [ __ ] like it everyone's just like
checking boxes Oh Gary Vee told me to
stop watching up to go do I've
unsubscribe from his youtube just a
bunch of [ __ ] keyboard warriors
everybody everybody's real [ __ ] fancy
on their Instagram photo and look and
their profile and what you say on
Twitter but nobody's [ __ ] doing it
like it's super easy to me to look in
your face and say eat [ __ ] for 10 years
because I did it I lived in New Jersey I
didn't go out in New York City in my
entire 20s that's just [ __ ] facts
that's hard for a 20 year old dude but I
was on a mission and by the way not all
of you should most of you should not be
on the mission that I'm on which means
you can go out and you can do things but
everybody's talking [ __ ] a lot of
[ __ ] talk lots of [ __ ] talk and
[ __ ] I'm telling you there's a bunch
of fakers in this room right now
some with some advice for the hiring
process for me I talked to people and I
go on my intuition
I've trust my intuition sometimes it's
right and sometimes it's wrong that's
why the your you're being too slow
you're letting your your your not
listening to if you're debating that or
struggling with that then you haven't
you haven't actually consumed the
message usually it's your own ego that's
stopping you you don't want to make the
wrong call you don't want somebody to
trick you I love you guys tricking me I
don't care
trick me I'm in control if you're in
control you know so you're letting your
ego get in the way so just make the gut
instinct make it good in singing and
[ __ ] not hiring stuff watch is why
firing is not hiring you don't know
firing you know babban sucks you know
oh all of the advices work if you get
the right money that's great it speeds
it up I love going slower because then
you're in full control people understand
when they when they take in money
they've lost control everybody think
everybody thinks that what window
WordPress and all the and Squarespace
are way [ __ ] ahead of you I don't
give a [ __ ] they're way ahead of you
like like you're right like like you're
not closing a window you're finding a
carve-out do you understand everybody
thinks like everybody's sitting here
with like a night like literally the
besides that besides I'm gonna help you
buy the Jets the quickest way to get me
to actually not hear anything and turn
you into Charlie Brown is when you say
I've got such a big idea I'm gonna
patent it I literally literally am on to
the next thing
like literally like a yeah okay next
like I don't think you're I don't think
you're gonna lose a window I think
you're carving out you know a window a
cue window is innovating not in the
feature set but innovating when you're
feature setting or slight you know you
are if you're a platform that helps
people have a website you're not losing
a window you have a feature coming that
is giving you some carve out features as
everybody has learned are easily
replicatable if one chooses to so I
don't think you're overthinking the
window which then will help you be more
patient well then we'll get you to the
right place got it everybody thinks
they're sitting on something nobody's
sitting on something nobody in this
nobody who decided to come to see me is
sitting on something it's just okay you
know you understand I'm not sitting on
something I'm just executing ahead I'm
just executing so fast cuz I don't
overthink a lot of these things that you
guys are talking about which lets me go
fast people are slow cuz they're in
their heads so I don't think you're
sitting on a window I think you're
sitting on a feature and you probably
have some talent and so I'll just keep
putting brick by brick what is making
you not jump all in usually
not crazy results in a short period of
time which means you're looking for you
know you're not looking for marriages
you're looking for hookups that's why
you haven't figured it out everybody
thinks that everybody is unstuck it's
you know what this is a great three two
themes in a row everybody stuck on the
idea of it guys it's not the idea of it
ways wasn't a new innovation right
Instagram wasn't a new innovation
Spotify wasn't a new in it like guys
it's like you know it's like its
execution so usually people are bouncing
around their businesses because they
think I could come up with idea it's
gonna launch and [ __ ] Nirvana is
gonna come you know it's just not it's
[ __ ] execution nothing I've ever done
in my life is some new thing I've just
done it better
harder longer like it's just in the
edges Elon Musk is not in this room
right now you understand
so you're bouncing around because you're
not getting the traction that you're
looking for because you're probably
judging way too fast
vaynermedia sucks [ __ ] the first two
years me and AJ had a long debate about
selling it for a million dollars to
buddy media twenty nine months in yeah I
mean like everybody's like things like
guys most people are not actual
entrepreneurs and you we are as a
collective universe right now being
tricked that we are just keep that in
mind my man what's up bro yeah yeah yeah
for me if I was graduating today I think
the best advice I'm giving to that
person is to work for the person they
want to be for free tell me what
industry you love let's write down 15
people that [ __ ] dominate it right
now
you know and dominate it not like they
were legends in it and maybe like
they're falling off like who heard real
players and figure out how to [ __ ]
work for them for free which is hard
when you have debt which is hard when
you want to prove yourself to the world
which is hard you know but it is the
move it is the move it I will I'm really
happy about this one because I've been
on this kick for a long time I'm so
positive I'm gonna be historically
correct about this I'm positive that
this is good I think when the college
debt crisis takes down our country the
same thing will happen to colleges that
happen to banks we're gonna blame the
colleges not the kids in here who are
borrowing money even though they have
debt okay it's not even bad the worst
part is the worst part is that people
are getting lent money with the debt
it's not the debt like if you didn't
have any options your parents aren't
gonna pay for your school like you were
of an age where you know all of us
including you youngsters are still of an
age where college is the right move like
right but like you know like they it's
not bad it's that it's that 26 year olds
right now with $400,000 in debt are
getting lent five hundred thousand
dollars to buy a BMW and an apartment
and they have no shot of ever making
that work it's just gonna happen again
we're like minutes away just think about
your life over the next seven years very
carefully financially very carefully
because I think the extremes have a
potential to be extremely hardcore and
you can get tricked with fruitfulness
that's built on [ __ ] so I'm gonna
refer somebody for free man
yeah yeah but it's but the thematics
you've got the thematics right like
there's real market places an artificial
market places right you know it's crazy
go ahead yes the shoe store
I want to update it yes if your family
business is not doing fifty percent of
its business on online
direct-to-consumer in 36 to 48 months
you're gonna be in real trouble Shopify
shop a [ __ ] fie Shopify Shopify
Instagram Facebook go I like Pinterest
but I think I think I like Pinterest but
I like print Pinterest says like I like
it
I [ __ ] adore Instagram and Facebook
yeah the guy in the back with glasses
yep like
here's why especially as young as you
are a lot of people liked playing video
games 20 years ago but they became
lawyers they wished I mean great ones
they wish they'd stayed playing video
games because it'd be the Tony Hawk of
eSports today like you always have to
get as young as you are you have to bet
15 more years unlike and hope that that
turns into more you know what I mean
like again I got it really good because
what I was doing in being an
entrepreneur during when I was doing it
was frowned upon it who's over 40 here
right so we know there was no
entrepreneurship I got these in F's
which meant I had no shot of being
successful in my life that is
fundamentally how it was you can't you
gotta understand if you're under 25
under 30 that's hard for you to
understand there was no internet there's
no internet let's start there there was
no [ __ ] internet right and so like
and so it was [ __ ] school to job or
you're like we have not what this what
we have not done is understood what the
internet is yet that's what this books
about that's what's coming out of my
mouth right now it's real early like I
think the MBA is gonna go out of
business and I think it's the number one
sport it's got the best situation I just
think the players have all the leverage
I just think the next generation of
LeBron and Carmelo and Durant's are
gonna look at each other and be like
[ __ ] it let's just own the teams
ourselves let I'll be captain I'll get
it right let's get a billion dollars per
from a brand to pay for the stadiums and
all that [ __ ] when we could deal with
Facebook for people to watch like it's
over the middle is over like my ability
to compete with your family business and
my ability to compete with my own family
business like selling wine direct
consumer or shoes like like of my shoes
like as comfortable as they are I'm sure
with that many years of tradition
there's such great relationships but
money talks and so like it's just over
it's so much bigger than people think
I'll get your bow I'll get these two and
I'll go what we produce two ads we have
no ads that we created we're sailors
still at a place where we're the second
creative team there's still the
television creative team and we're not
trying to necessarily jockey for that
because we think you know for example is
this right Tyler that Comcast's Olympic
thing right like so like like what we're
getting there but they'll probably two
or three more Super Bowls before it's
like these are our spots you know my man
yes yes yes yep it's supplying the man
brother it's just it's not just it's not
just I don't feel bad for musicians the
same way I don't feel bad for a fourth
generation shoe store
it's supplying a man it's the cats out
of the bag you're not gonna make the
same economics you have to build your
brand so you can make money other ways
too much music too many producers no no
it's the most [ __ ] important part of
cold-like music's top five in life but
that but that has nothing to do don't
get confusion of of separating what it
means creatively and what it means from
a business standpoint yeah well I'll
tell you I'm gonna find you here it is
ready yeah you're not gonna make money
the same way because screaming is gonna
get bigger not smaller then something
else will come along but the number one
thing you should do is you need to [ __ ]
technology before it [ __ ] you right so
you need to use Instagram and Facebook
and these platforms to build up your
brand so people want to [ __ ] with you 24
hours at Metro boomin and Sonny digital
they're not struggling right and Richy
South is not gonna struggle because he's
growing in his platform you need to
build your [ __ ] personal brand it's
only thing you control
personal brand is the leverage point
that you can then put my business plan
did not include a dollar sneaker deal my
business deal had a strategy of have the
attention and then decide what to do
with it if you you your I you're
thinking about it - technically let's
take a step back build a [ __ ] brand
every one of them then people want to
pay you more to produce their [ __ ] then
a brand wants to reach out to you for
you to produce something got it it's
agnostic get the let the only leverage
we're playing for right now is attention
this is share of attention I don't think
I compete with Tony Robbins or Elon Musk
or Richard Branson I think I compete
with [ __ ] 21 Savage and [ __ ]
karl-anthony towns
anybody who can have attention is my
[ __ ] competition that book you
[ __ ] driving like you sleeping is my
[ __ ] competition attention is the
[ __ ] game cool see ya yes meet each
other there's more [ __ ] there hi guys
thank you so much of course man
I like your thought process man work for
somebody to free I'm telling you right
now getting to listen to me getting
closest to the Sun is where all the
leverages people don't understand look
these two [ __ ] guys are so much
further ahead of everything his whole
career has already made how long have
you worked for me three years hey if he
wants to work for Steven Spielberg it's
sad like people don't get it get as
close to that people gonna pay me two
hundred thousand dollars a year to work
for me in five years that's what's gonna
happen when people understand right now
the biggest steal of all time is to
[ __ ] get Mark Cuban's coffee to get
PPD's shoes cleaned once you get into
the vortex if you're smart I could tell
you're smart if you suck then make
people get in and then they get out but
if you're good and you can get closest
to the Sun it's over
[Music]